[Musique]
bonsoir donc je m'appelle valérie vitter
mouradian je suis bancaire depuis un peu
plus de 30 ans dans le secteur de la
banque d'investissement
mais ya 32 ans
j'étais à l'iss
donc comme alice au pays des merveilles
et comme peut-être et même sûrement un
grand nombre d'entre vous un moment clé
de choix dans votre vie
j'avais beaucoup d'optimisme et une
volonté d'aller de l'avant un peu
candide à mai
mais très présente
et donc comme alice quand elle se jette
dans le dans le terroir dans le terrier
où elle des coûts tout est inconnu et où
elle comprend pas vraiment les codes
j'avais moi même pas vraiment les codes
du monde professionnel et de la façon
dont on devait évoluer dans ce monde
mais j'avais une volonté farouche
de réussir
d'avancé de commencer mac est en quelque
sorte et
et de prendre ce qu'il y avait ce qu'il
y avait de meilleur pour le faire
je voyais un peu autour de moi peut-être
un peu comme alice toujours dans cette
idée très de débutantes ou on comprend
pas trop ce qui se passe où il ya des
personnages qui passent des apparences
qui sont étrangères et
ont grandi en rapetissant fin on a du
mal à trouver ses repères
mais ce qui compte c'est d'essayer
d'aller chercher à trouver les codes à
les comprendre alors pas simplement les
codes se sont pas tous mais mais c'est
un grand c'est un grand début et c'est
très clairement une aide une aide
importante
si je suis lâche ce soir devant vous
c'est parce que je veux réveiller en
chacun d'entre vous votre capital
leadership et vous aider à poursuivre
votre propre quête professionnel
c'est par l'engagement par la recherche
de l'équilibré par l'impact que j'ai
réussi à mener un ma carrière
si je suis aussi devant vous ce soir
c'est parce que je pense c'est le sens
de mon engagement je pense que quand on
a reçu il faut donner et 1 je pense
aussi que il faut chercher des soutiens
qu'il faut qu'il faut s'ouvrir qu'il
faut échanger et que c'est comme ça
qu'on
qu'on progresse
alors après l'introduction avec alice
peut vous paraître
un peu
biaisé on va dire parce qu'elle fait
référence à une une femme c'est une
référence genre et féminine
écoutez je vais vous dire une chose
j'accepte d'avoir une référence féminine
mais si vous me réinviter une prochaine
fois en prochain tedx bas je prendrai le
petit prince comme ça on fera un 50 50
et ce 50 50 c'est vraiment
profondément
ce à quoi je crois il ment mon
engagement dans la diversité et la
promotion de l'égalité professionnelle
donc c'est bien par mon expérience que
j'ai envie de partager avec vous ma
quête ma carrière au travers de
différents de différents exemples et
points clés de ma de ma progression
pour vous montrer que dans ce monde de
la banque et de la banque
d'investissement
on peut réussir avec une recherche de l'
équilibre à trouver à ay ay avoir une
bonne une belle carrière professionnelle
donc si si je reprends un peu si je
reprends en repart un peu en arrière
de formation je suis ingénieur en
mathématiques et en informatique
et ensuite j'ai fait un troisième cycle
hec en finance internationale
c'était assez nouveau à l'époque c'est
maintenant c'est maintenant très très
répandue et c'est parce que je voulais
vraiment compléter compléter mon
expérience à me développer chercher
quelque chose de différent j'ai toujours
eu un caractère très affirmé dès le plus
jeune âge donc avec des choix très
tranchées et ses choix sont des choix
qui qui me permettent de me motiver et
de trouver une vraiment une
détermination une détermination forte
j'avais pas particulièrement de
référence dans le monde professionnel où
dans le monde économique
j'étais une petite provinciale j'ai
grandi à grenoble au milieu des pistes
de ski mes parents étaient chercheur au
cnrs et je peux vous dire qu'on parlait
pas du tout finances à la maison et
encore mois encore moins économies mais
j'étais attirée pourquoi j'ai été attiré
parce que j'avais envie de comprendre
l'environnement dans lequel j'étais on
était au début à la fin des années 80 il
faut se souvenir qu'à la fin des années
80 c'est le moment le cac 40 est né
c'est le moment où les marchés dérivés
actions ont commencé à se développer en
france et c'est aussi le moment des
premières privatisations avec avec le
gouvernement balladur et je voyais tout
ça et j'avais envie de trouver les codes
de trouver les clés
donc je suis rentré je suis rentré dans
la banque j'ai commencé par la banque
parle asset management en
comme dot voilà il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'ingénieurs qui sont rentrés dans les
salles des marchés qui ont d'ailleurs
fait des belles carrières mais moi
j'avais choisi une voie différente et
petites anecdotes comme quoi quand je
suis arrivé quand je suis arrivé dans
l'équipe en fait
l'équipe venait de recevoir le premier
ordinateur personnel avant il y avait
que des traitements de texte et donc on
m'a dit ah bah tiens toi tu es
ingénieurs donc tu vas savoir tu vas
savoir ton servir est donc loin d'être
un trophée pour moi je suis dit qu'il
fallait que j'utilisais que je me serve
de de ce que j'avais quelque part en
plus de différent par rapport aux autres
collègues pour faire progresser
l'activité et pour ouvrir des chambres
et pour innover dans des domaines dans
lequel savait pas été fait avant donc
c'est comme ça que j'ai développé des
modèles d' analyses
quantitatives sur les allocations
d'actifs sur un certain nombre de choses
donc j'ai perdu mais je me suis bien
développé j'ai bien progressé j'ai j'ai
en même temps à développer aussi
commencé un peu maquettes et commençait
un peu à trouver mon équilibre
je me suis
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer pas mal
de monde bien sûr dans le monde
professionnel on rencontre énormément de
monde aimait de d'avoir à 502 personnes
qui m'ont poussée qui m'ont aidé à faire
des choix et là dessus c'est un conseil
qu'on ne donne jamais assez aux jeunes
il faut et aux moins jeunes d'ailleurs
il faut il faut toujours osé demander
toujours osé poser des questions
toujours toujours osé partager partager
ses convictions je dois dire que j'ai eu
de la chance j'ai dans cet univers et
dans mon environnement professionnel
j'ai eu aussi la chance de
d'avoir de rands avoir rencontré mon
mari on était stagiaire dans l'âme dans
la même équipe donc
[Musique]
on se disputait d'ailleurs l'ordinateur
le fameux et
[Musique]
c'est ça qui m'a aussi porter qui m'a
permis de d'être équilibrés dans
dans mon monde professionnel et dans ma
vie au quotidien donc après finalement
grosso modo j'ai découvert mon code j'ai
permis
de sortir du terrier de sortir de
l'inconnu et au bout de huit ans j'avais
j'avais un peu fait le tour de
l'environnement dans lequel j'étais
et j'avais envie d'aller plus loin
j'étais très très attiré par le milieu
de la banque d'affaires
par tout ce que ça représentait par le
côté intellectuel et accomplissant du
sujet et donc j'ai eu l'opportunité de
rejoindre abm amro rothschild
qui est une entité spécialisée dans le
crm le marché le marché primaire actions
les introductions en bourse les
augmentations de capital
et je dois dire que
voilà après huit ans j'étais bien
j'avais l'impression que je maîtrisais
plein de choses que je connaissais pas
mal de choses et je suis arrivé dans un
univers complètement nouveau et là
franchement ça a été un ça a été un vrai
choc ça a été un vrai choc et et pendant
une année
j'ai pas vraiment douté parce que
j'étais en retour entouré de personnes
qui me soutenaient mais j'ai vraiment dû
j'ai vraiment dû travailler travailler
très dur j'ai travaillé très dur et très
intensément mais quelque part en même
temps j'avais aussi j'avais aussi cette
cette quête et 7 et cette recherche de
l'équilibré kim emporté c'est au même
moment que on a décidé de fonder une
vraie famille avec avec mon mari est
donc il ya mon mon fils aîné victor qui
est né en 1998 mon deuxième fils jules
qui est qui est né en 2001 et ça m'a
donné la force 7 cette famille cette
stabilité cet équilibre m'a donné la
force d'aller au bout de moi même
alors vous allez me dire elle parle
beaucoup des kill him mais finalement
c'est quoi les équilibres c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle en parle lors aujourd'hui
on galvaude un peu ça on dit oui ce qui
est important c'est d'avoir un c'est
d'avoir une vie pro et vie perso
équilibrés ont certes c'est un peu sale
équilibre mais pas que
l'équilibré c'est c'est travailler sur
plein de facettes c'est de s'assurer
qu'on qu'on ne déstabilise pas quelque
chose au service de l'autre c'est
s'assurer que on est finalement
accomplie et qu'on arrive à trouver de
la satisfaction dans tout ce qu'on fait
et c'est surtout ne pas regretter ses
choix ne pas regretter de ne pas avoir
une enfant pour sa carrière
professionnelle de ne pas avoir ne pas
regretter de ne pas choisir une
opportunité qui s'offre à vous pour
d'autres choses donc donc voilà les qui
voilà pour moi ce qui est ce qui l
équilibre et cet équilibre m'a permis à
une fois que je suis arrivé en banque
d'affaires de temps découvrez les codes
pour ceux qui ont fait des stages vous
savez que c'est un monde qui est très
exigeant qui à l'époque était encore
plus masculin qu'il était aujourd'hui
donc j'ai travaillé comme une arche né
un jour et nuit et j'ai je me suis dit
que
j'allais y arriver et j'y suis arrivé
j'ai été aidé j'avais des role models
j'ai jamais eu une personne en
particulier aux prêts auxquels je me
suis identifiée mais un certain nombre
de femmes ou d'hommes d'ailleurs auquel
je prenais ce que je trouvais
intéressant est ce qui pouvait me
convenir aussi
donc c'est vraiment
7,7 cette première étape quelque part
qui qui qui m'a permis de grandir et qui
m'a permis
dalé d'aller dans ma quête et de
finalement me réalisée aussi
professionnellement
donc ensuite
[Musique]
j'avais près c'est une première étape on
va dire et on était on était au début on
était dans les années
2001 2002 à les marchés financiers
étaient toujours très très porteur et
est source de nombreuses de nombreuses
opportunités
j'avais eu la chance
de travailler avec de très grands
clients sur la naissance de eads et
airbus aujourd'hui sur la bourse sur
euronext sur sur france télécom qui est
orange aujourd'hui et je me souviens
très très bien quand après avoir
travaillé pendant pendant des mois sur
la recapitalisation de france télécom
mon patron de l'époque un hollandais
que pour l'anecdote
1,5 en avant quand j'avais vu quand
j'avais peur je l'avais rencontré la
première fois à londres je ne comprenais
pas un mot de ce qu'il me disait il me
parlait d'un jargon que je ne comprenais
pas ils me parlaient en anglais avec
l'accent hollandais j'avais travaillé
dans la cette maj main en france mais
bon 8 cinq ans après il m'invita à
madrid lors d'une conférence des
dirigeants de la banque et lors du dîner
de gala le soir il me dit tiens valérie
je voudrais tu je voulais devrais te
présenter quelqu'un est là il me
présente il me présente au patron de la
banque de l'époque et puis il me dit
valérie you are now parts of the family
and we want you to know that you have
over delivered
et franchement vous pouvez pas imaginer
j'étais dans un état de fatigue absolue
comment ces mots résonnent encore au
fond de moi et comment de ce simple
geste en fait j'en ai tiré
une vraie leçon de leadership et une
vraie leçon de manager
cette leçon est bien entendu que il faut
reconnaître les efforts des uns et des
autres que le succès se reconnaît le
succès se fait le succès se partagent
que la réussite est collective
et c'est vraiment et c'est vraiment ça
qui m'a ensuite motivé en tant qu' en
tant que manager quand j'ai pris quand
j'ai pris la direction de l'activité
pour le mettre moi-même en application
au delà des valeurs auxquelles je
croyais qu'ils sont bien sûr le fait
d'être pas bien sûr pas forcément mais
moi mon nom mon style est un style
plutôt d'exigence 1 mais de
reconnaissance de
deux réussites collectives et
individuelles
et surtout d'arriver à apporter les
membres de l'équipe par par l'ambition
par l'ambition collective par le fait de
montrer un la lumière la lumière au bout
du bout du chemin
donc
[Musique]
quelque part j'étais vraiment j'étais
arrivé à un certain niveau qui était le
mien 1 et
et c'est là où je me suis dit que mon
maquettes et mon équilibre était pas et
est pas complet et qu'il fallait aussi
que que je complète et que nous
complétions
avec avec mon mari notre propre notre
propre voie c'est pour ça qu'on a eu la
chance ben j'ai eu la chance de tomber
enceinte et d'avoir à presque 40 ans mon
troisième enfant mathieu on est en 2005
et là c'est un moment très important au
delà de la joie de la joie d'être
parents mais parce que là cette maturité
j'ai cette maternité je les fais tu dans
une dent énormément de sérénité alors
que franchement les deux premières un
peu moins et quand je juste avant que je
rentre de congé maternité une semaine
avant la banque m'a proposé d'aller dans
une de suivre une formation d'une
semaine et cette formation à s'appelait
authentique hummel leadership
il ça a été pour moi une vraie
électrochoc une révélation
parce que pendant une semaine 1 j'ai
côtoyé des femmes qui travaillent dans
des milieux très différents de la banque
mais qui finalement avait eu elle aussi
leurs propres quêtes avait eu aussi leur
propre questionnement et qu'on était
arrivés par des choses que vous
connaissez peut-être j'espère qu'on vous
enseigne ici comme les bien conscient
comme les différents styles de
leadership
c'était que des choses qui résonnait en
moi et qui
est que franchement je n'avais pas
vraiment conscience avant donc quand je
suis rentré de s'être de cette formation
j'étais encore beaucoup plus énergique
qui avant j'avais envie de manger le
monde et puis surtout j'avais envie de
partager j'avais envie
de permettre à nos organes à
l'organisation dans lequel j'étais de
donner confiance à d'autres femmes et de
permettre à d'autres à d'autres femmes
de réussir et de peut-être tiré le deux
sets de cette expérience et c'est
vraiment là que j'ai que j'ai eu une
vraie motivation pour pour le sujet de
la promotion de la promotion de la
diversité
non pas parce que enfin déjà parce que
c'est une cause juste mais au delà de la
justesse de cette cause parce que c'est
une façon à de délivrer plus de
les organisations diverses sont des
organisations beaucoup beaucoup plus
performante à et c'est pour ça que quand
après avoir rejoint hsbc en en 2013
en 2015
j'ai eu l'opportunité de devenir la
présidente de l'association de la
promotion
pour la mixité
et là je me suis dit que c'était
l'opportunité dose et
à faire en sorte que les autres aux as
c'était aussi l'opportunité de
convaincre d'engager
sur cette cause et ça a été ça a été une
grande une grande source de joie et de
satisfaction en plus vous savez
vous avez de nombreuses associations ici
le monde associatif est à la fois
quelque chose dont on se nourrit quand
on quand on anime l'animation quand on
anime l'association
mais c'est aussi quelque chose qui
bénéficie à l'ensemble à l'ensemble des
membres et donc tous les ateliers de
développement personnel les coachings à
les conférences les les after work
tous ces éléments qui ont bénéficié à
des centaines d'hommes et de femmes et
qui leur ont permis de se développer de
trouver leur chemin de vie leur chemin
de carrière sont des éléments qui qui
reste très marquant puis comme je toute
chose au bout de cinq ans il faut aussi
savoir passer la main faut savoir passer
la main des jeunes inde et des nouvelles
personnes il faut aussi dans son
engagement poursuivre sa quête et
poursuivre poursuivre son engagement
c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça que je
me suis engagé il ya il ya un peu plus
d'une année au sein de deux financière
pour
pour pousser plus loin le sujet alors
financière qu'est ce que c'est pour ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas ce financieele
c'est la fédération des groupes les
réseaux de promotion de la mixité dans
le secteur de la banque et de
l'assurance donc donc c'est vraiment
l'idée de a
d'influencé d'influencé au niveau des
politiques d'influencé au niveau des
dirigeants pour avoir des entreprises
plus juste et une égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes qu'ils soient plus réfléchi et
qui soit à l'ensemble à l'ensemble des
niveaux de l'organisation alors vous me
direz une quête de plus pour valérie
finalement à l'oeil que des quêtes dans
sa vie pas du tout enfin je le vois pas
comme ça ce que je vois c'est comme un
continuum et ce que je vois c'est que
ces quêtes me permettent de garder mon
équilibre de me2 de trouver ma voie
entre l'ensemble des sujets sur lequel
je suis engagé et sur lequel je pense
avoir de l'impact
donc
finalement qu'est-ce qui est ce qui
reste qu est ce qui reste de tout ça et
comment et comment est ce que j'ai pu
j'ai pu développer un ce capital
leadership et comment je suis sûr vous
allez pouvoir le faire vous demain
c'est bien sûr par un par cet engagement
par le fait de de trouver des alliés de
d'accepter les soutiens d'aller les
chercher dosé de capitaliser sur les
forces je serais jamais arrivé je suis
là où je suis arrivé si j'avais pas
finalement fait mes différences une
force et si je les avais pas cultiver un
c'est aussi l'engagement le le travail
le sens du collectif et la diversité
parce que je suis persuadé que en tout
on se nourrit de cette différence c'est
que c'est cette différence qui fait
notre force donc voilà ce que je voulais
échanger avec vous ce soir il y à de
superbes opportunités dans le monde dans
le monde de la dans le monde de la
finance je vous souhaite une très très
belle deux très très belle carrière quel
que soit quel que soit ce que vous ce
que vous cherchiez souvenez-vous 1
franchement j'étais vraiment à l'iss il
ya 32 ans donc si j'ai réussi ma quête
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas fini vous
réussirez la vôtre merci
[Applaudissements]